let's talk about yoga mats and fast food
because yeah there's a chemical that is
in yoga mats that of course is in your
fast food you thought it was all pink
slime but no it's it's even worse
patience Jimmy you'll see in just a
moment
it's called a Zoda carbon ID I think I
got that close to correct we'll give me
predict the correct pronunciation down
below and it is in a ton of fast food
Subway announced last week they're not
going to use it in their bread anymore
that's for the six inch or the footlong
but we've got a list of other companies
that are using it this includes
McDonald's chick-fil-a Burger King
Dunkin Donuts Wendy's Arby's
jack-in-the-box Carl's jr. Hardee's and
White Castle basically the reason subway
is dropping it is because there was an
online petition which garnered about
80,000 signatures this substance is
already banned in Europe really yes at
the Center for science and public
interests want it banned completely here
in the United States but of course that
isn't happening and we're so far leaving
it up to these companies all of those
still have it Subway's getting rid of it
should this just not surprise us well
every time we do these stories on pink
slime and literally they're the reason
they use it is because it makes the
bread more elastic and spongy here like
a yoga mat so it's literally you
downward dog right onto your sandwich
yeah yeah what is going on in this
country with this kind of stuff we're
used to it I mean I have friends that
come here from other countries get super
fat in like two weeks and like slow down
turned gray and we're just used to it we
don't know what the problem is we know
what their problem is I haven't eaten
that [ __ ] in a while and I had like some
McDonald's and I honestly couldn't eat
the bread because of the sponge factor
it freaked me out and now I know why
yeah it literally is a sponge it's it's
it's literally a sponge and if you're
into it [ __ ] it
we've been eating this stuff since we
were kids it's mature it's all you know
it's it's it's in our it's it's in who
we are it's it's bound to our DNA it's
not gonna matter at this point
but if it grosses you out but for the
love of God stop eating it what does
this chemical actually do does it until
your body does it cause cancer or maybe
a heart problem maybe memory loss Dave
well Jimmy good question because some
researchers think it causes cancer so
yeah this
the stuff we're putting in our body and
I think you're right we've just done
this stuff for so long that you see the
pink slime video and you're like you
find out yoga mats are in your buns and
you go and that's the thing like you're
eating this [ __ ] and it's all made of
plastic and you're eating it you're
consuming it you're putting it in your
stomach you can't even breathe it's
probably blurring your vision it's
you're it's making you fat it's making
you obese and you're like oh CBS doesn't
have cigarettes okay like none of this
[ __ ] like what does it matter I'm
feeling sort of nihilistic but what is
it what does any of this [ __ ] matter
because we're not gonna stop eating it
anyway going down a dark hole deep fried
like pop tops from milk jugs we'll eat
anything as long as you stick it in the
fryer isn't it all right as Americans to
eat crap and suffer the consequences
later or as that commercial with
what's-his-name the plumber the Cable
Guy yeah I eat corn dogs all day long
and they not take pepcid like isn't that
our right as Americans to be fat [ __ ]
who are unhealthy and eating car you
know eating plastic and isn't that what
America is all about you know as Chris
Christie said mistakes were made anyway
yes it is our right to eat theirs
it's funny you talked about how that
chemicals already banned in Europe
there's lots of stuff that's already
been out Europe but it's because the
corporations that have much more control
of the government in America than they
do in Europe that we have to eat Franken
food as a one judge called Chicken
McNugget Nuggets right half of its foam
[ __ ] mats and the and the other half
is chicken knuckles no I mean did you
guys see there's a video on YouTube now
where McDonald's in Canada did a thing
about a three-minute video we'll link to
it here where they said people think we
use pink sign but we don't and then they
show you the actual process and I assure
you the process ain't pretty either it's
just great yeah it's not pink it's gray
so that thing and and like you said do
we have the right to be fat Fox totally
but I think we also have the right to
know what's causing us to be fat Fox
yeah if it's just you know high
cholesterol good old-fashioned butter
and lard hey knock yourself out but if
we're eating yoga mats we should have
the right to know that we're eating okay
so if we don't have the right to be fat
[ __ ] in America there's a lot of people
at risk of being arrested right now
that's all I'm saying it have mass
incarceration and I mean mass
man we're gonna underline the math
alright so last thought on this joking
aside though is the real issue here that
we are just so separated from our food
like the I you know people used to have
land and grow their food and you know
you want some vegetables we'll go pick
them you want some herbs go pick them
and now our food is so separate from us
we don't know what the hell is going on
is there any way to reverse that process
you know for instance Mike I was I'm a
big Italian food person and so my I used
to date this girl who had family there
when we go visit they would like you
visit their family to go they go kill a
chicken we'd come in they get so yes it
was it was right there so you were
connected to the food you were connect
now it comes to that make you crazy like
oh god I can't look no I thought wasn't
that neat look at that and it actually
tastes better to course it does because
a lot of people will say like I'm sorry
I can't eat anything with bones in it
and like you know what what did you just
say like they're eating all this crazy
[ __ ] but they don't want you're
absolutely right they don't want to be
connected to it they don't want any part
of it and they're very happy to be like
that and speaking of bones correct me if
I'm wrong but I'm pretty sure they're
allowed to put in a certain percentage
of bone in McDonald's beef so yeah
you're not getting away from the bones
that easy